supongamos que estoy muy interesada en
encontrar cuál es la relación entre la
altura de las personas en centímetros y
su peso en kilogramos entonces me puse a
medir la altura y el peso de personas
que escogía al azar y para cada persona
estoy graficando un punto con su altura
y su peso entonces por ejemplo si tomo a
una persona que mide un metro ochenta
osea 180 centímetros y que pesa 50
kilogramos entonces voy a poner un punto
aquí y este punto es el punto ciento
80,50 otra forma de pensar en esto es
pensar que la altura la estamos
graficando en el eje x y el peso lo
estamos graficando en el eje y esta
persona está en el punto 180 con 50
donde 180 nos dice que su altura es 180
centímetros y 50 nos dice que su peso
son 50 kilogramos
pero bueno por el momento hemos tomado
estas mediciones para uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve
personas y yo podría seguir agregando
datos a esta gráfica pero incluso con
los datos que ya tenemos aquí podemos
ver cierta tendencia cierta relación
entre la altura y el peso parece como
que tenemos una relación lineal por acá
y parece como que es una relación
positiva eso lo que significa es que
entre más aumentemos la altura más
aumenta el peso ahora con estos datos
que tenemos aquí podemos seguir nuestra
intuición y tal vez podemos dibujar una
línea recta que aproxime la tendencia de
estos datos y para eso vamos a utilizar
una herramienta que tengo por aquí esta
es una herramienta que tengo para
dibujar líneas rectas pero si dibujamos
cualquier línea por ejemplo si dibujamos
esta línea no estamos representando la
tendencia de estos datos por ejemplo con
esta línea podemos observar que la
mayoría de los datos
por debajo de la línea entonces no es
una buena aproximación también podemos
hacer algo como esto pero esta tampoco
es una buena aproximación porque la
mayoría de los datos se encuentra por
encima de la recta pero bueno por el
momento simplemente estamos dibujando
estas líneas con nuestra intuición no lo
estamos haciendo de una forma precisa
pero próximamente vamos a aprender
métodos muy buenos para encontrar una
mejor aproximación pero bueno esta recta
que estoy dibujando por acá parece que
es una aproximación suficientemente
buena esta línea la podemos ver como la
recta de una regresión lineal y su
ecuación es igual a m x + b pero aquí
todavía nos falta calcular la pendiente
y la ordenada al origen ok esto es nada
más lo que observamos por acá pero
también lo podemos ver de otra forma
podemos ver esta ecuación como que el
peso es igual a la pendiente
la altura más lo que sea la ordenada al
origen que hay aquí para encontrar ve
tenemos que ver en qué valor del peso se
intersecta esta línea pero bueno este es
simplemente el modelo que encontramos
aproximando lo con nuestra intuición
esta es una aproximación de una recta de
regresión lineal y es algo que estamos
tratando de ajustar a los datos que
tenemos y bueno aquí en este ejemplo
parece como que la recta pasa por estos
tres puntos pero no podemos hacer que la
recta pase por todos los datos que
tenemos en esta gráfica y siempre va a
haber una diferencia entre el dato que
tenemos y lo que pudimos haber predicho
con esta recta puede haber un par de
puntos que si se encuentran en la recta
pero eso no sucede para la mayoría de
los puntos pero justo esa idea la
diferencia que hay entre el punto y lo
que hubiéramos predicho con la recta de
la regresión lineal esa diferencia se
llama residuo vamos a escribirlo por acá
si obtenemos un residuo para cada uno de
los datos entonces y por ejemplo a este
dato le decimos que es el dato número
uno vamos a obtener un residuo para este
dato y lo podemos llamar el residuo 1 y
el residuo lo vamos a sacar así nos
vamos a basar en la altura 180
centímetros y para este dato que tiene
180 centímetros tiene un peso de 50
kilogramos por lo que vamos a poner aquí
los 50 kilogramos ya esto le vamos a
restar el peso que esta línea predice
para una persona de 180 centímetros de
altura y lo que esta línea predice para
una persona de 180 centímetros lo
podemos encontrar en este punto si
tuviéramos la pendiente y la ordenada al
origen calculados podríamos simplemente
sustituir 180 centímetros en la altura y
obtendríamos el peso que predice este
modelo
es que podemos poner por aquí 180 por m
b y otra vez lo único que hice aquí es
tomar la altura de esta persona 180
centímetros y preguntarnos qué peso
perdices este modelo para esa altura
pero bueno como no conocemos a m llave y
queremos tener aquí un número preciso
vamos a borrar esta parte y vamos a ver
el valor de esta aproximación esta si
parece como una línea recta entonces
vamos a ver a qué valor corresponde esa
altura entonces este modelo predice 75
kilogramos para una persona de 180
centímetros por lo que el residuo de
este dato es de menos 25 nuestro residuo
resulta ser un número negativo y eso
sucede cuando los datos se encuentran
por debajo de la línea de nuestro modelo
esto por aquí es el residuo
1 y es un residuo negativo pero claro
también podemos tener residuos positivos
por ejemplo si tratamos de encontrar el
residuo de este dato que se encuentra
arriba de la línea del modelo bueno pues
este residuo r2 es un residuo positivo
porque el valor real del peso es mayor
que el valor que hubiera predicho el
modelo pero bueno todo esto de los
residuos nos sirve para evaluar qué tan
bueno es este modelo que tanto nuestra
regresión lineal se ajusta a los datos
que tenemos estos residuos
nos dicen que tanto la regresión se
ajusta a los datos reales que tenemos
pero bueno una de las cosas muy
importantes en las que es muy bueno
pensar es en cómo podemos minimizar
estos residuos los residuos nos sirven
para saber que tanto nuestra regresión
lineal se ajusta a los datos reales pero
bueno una cosa muy importante en la que
sería bueno que pienses es en cómo
combinar todos
asiduos de los datos y en cómo minimizar
esa combinación de residuos en estos
momentos tú podrías decir oye por qué no
simplemente sumamos todos los residuos
de los datos y después vemos la forma de
minimizar los pero hay una cosa que
tenemos que tomar en cuenta tenemos
residuos positivos pero también tenemos
residuos negativos y a la hora de
sumarlos se cancelarían esos residuos y
la suma de los residuos podría incluso
llegar a ser cero y parecería como que
realmente no tenemos residuos aunque si
los tenemos por lo que no podemos
simplemente sumarlos pero lo que sí
podemos hacer es sumar sus valores
absolutos podríamos considerar la suma
de los valores absolutos de todos los
residuos esta puede ser nuestra forma de
combinar los residuos pero ahora si lo
que queremos es minimizar esta expresión
bueno pues podemos buscar la recta que
haga que esta combinación de residuos
sea la más pequeña posible y para eso
pues simplemente tenemos que mover
la m y la ve esta sería una muy buena
forma de tratar de encontrar la
regresión lineal que mejor se ajusta a
estos datos pero también hay otras
formas de hacer esto y de hecho vamos a
ver la forma más usual de hacerlo lo que
más personas hacen en estadística es
tomar la suma de los residuos elevados
al cuadrado por supuesto siempre que
elevamos una cantidad al cuadrado el
resultado tiene que ser positivo así es
que ya estamos tomando en cuenta esta
parte de que no queremos que se
contrarresten los residuos pero además
esta técnica de elevar los residuos al
cuadrado tiene otras características por
ejemplo que los residuos que son grandes
a la hora de elevar los al cuadrado
cuentan mucho más que los residuos que
son pequeños porque cuando elevamos algo
al cuadrado entre más grande sea mucho
más grande se hace para que quede un
poco más claro vamos a poner por aquí
algunos números y sus cuadrados
correspondientes vamos a poner uno
y 4 la diferencia entre cada uno de
éstos es de 1
pero si los elevamos al cuadrado 1 al
cuadrado es 1 2 al cuadrado es 4 3 al
cuadrado es 9 y 4 al cuadrado es 16 los
cuadrados de estos números se vuelven
cada vez más grandes aquí la diferencia
es de 7 mientras que aquí la diferencia
es de 3 así es que como podemos observar
aquí entre más grande sea el residuo
cuando lo elevamos al cuadrado cuando
tomamos la suma de todos los residuos
elevados al cuadrado los residuos que
sean más grandes van a ser los que
tengan más peso en esta suma van a estar
aportando una mayor cantidad a esta suma
y vamos a ver en futuros vídeos que
existe una técnica llamada la técnica de
regresión de mínimos cuadrados
regresión de mínimos cuadrados vamos a
ver que existe esta técnica con la que
podemos encontrar una m y un ave con las
cuales se minimiza la suma de los
cuadrados de los residuos y esta técnica
es muy valiosa porque toma en cuenta que
tanto se están alejando los datos de la
recta y a los puntos que distan mucho
los toma más en cuenta y esta es una
técnica muy valiosa porque además le
pone mayor peso a los puntos que se
encuentran muy alejados del modelo y
encuentra la forma de minimizar todas
las distancias tomando en cuenta que tan
alejado se encuentran esos datos pero
por supuesto esto es simplemente una
introducción conceptual en los próximos
vídeos vamos a calcular tal cual
cuáles son los residuos y también vamos
a derivar esta fórmula que minimiza a
los valores de m&b
encontrando una recta que hace que se
minimice la suma de los cuadrados de los
residuos